thank you David
so I'm if Doki and Nicole of at
ut-austin and the bulk of what I'll
present is joint work with two great
collaborators Richard Cole at NYU and my
former postdoc at UT Austin Tennessee's
Leah Mears who is now at the National
Technical University of Athens in this
work was motivated by transportation and
the heavy road traffic congestion that
probably most of us sitting in this room
and watching perhaps have experienced
and we wanted to understand to what
extent diversity of user preferences in
terms of what routes we pick might help
alleviate traffic congestion so what is
traffic congestion is the phenomenon
that a lot of users end up using the
same route or the same link the same set
of resources and as a result those
routes or parts of routes become heavily
congested and everyone ends up
experiencing higher travel time than
they would if there was no one else on
on the route except for them and the
intuition is that if we all have diverse
preferences on our outing choices for
example some people may prefer longer
routes but with no tools or maybe paying
a lot of money just to have the fastest
route and so on it may be the traffic in
traffic of equilibrium in the resulting
traffic assignment people would kind of
spread out more so there would be each
individual route or link would be less
less congested and therefore everyone
would experience better overall traffic
travel time so how exactly do we model
diversity of user preferences or
heterogeneity so two examples came to
mind we came from it thinking from the
point of view of risk-averse user
preferences so many of you who commute
here in the Bay Area might be familiar
with those routing times
so if you were to come from Palo Alto to
the workshop today depending on when you
googled or when you search for your
optimal route you might have very
diverse travel time estimates this is
something that I did at noon so it's not
peak about traffic and the estimate was
one hour for the commute and in Russia
were four pm I think that first snapshot
it could go up to one hour and a half
but we cannot even rely on those
estimates because what they fail to take
into account well is the evolving
traffic congestion so for example it
happened to me already in the majority
of times I went to Palo Alto and back it
happened to me that I was given an
estimate of one hour for my commute but
by the time I got to Berkeley it
actually had been one hour and a half
and so the diversity in the situation
may arise from how users trade off the
mean and variance the expected travel
time the experience and the variability
and maybe if you're just going to work
if you happen to leave one place and go
to the other and you do that routinely
you maybe are sort of risk neutral here
about your average on a daily basis but
if you're going to the airport you're
extremely risk-averse and then your
trade-off mean and variance in a very
different way you'll have a much heavier
weight on from the burials another way
to capture diverse user preferences as I
mentioned is how users react to tolls so
some people hate tolls do not want to
pay them and will do anything to avoid
them and others have very high value for
their time and therefore they are
willing to pay money to save time and so
again diversity may arise in how people
trade-off money in time travel time and
money spent on tolls so is a preview of
our result we we thought as I said
intuitively that having diverse
preferences
would help alleviate traffic congestion
and result with smaller equilibrium
costs I now define this later to our
surprise diversity didn't seem to help
in many situations so in particular
there's a preview of our results we
arrived at the characterization in which
we establish the diversity helps when
everyone has the same source and
destination diversity always always
helps only if the network is
series-parallel and if the network is
not series parallel it doesn't
necessarily help and you can come up
with examples where actually diversity
hurts meaning you end up with a higher
overall total travel time and if we
allow multiple sources and destinations
then diversity helps if and only if the
network again is of a particular type
which we introduced here and we call
block matching and I'll define and
explain what it is later and again if it
is not of that type you can come up with
examples where diversity hurts so
there's a preview and let me go into the
formal model so we have a directed graph
with a G with a set of nodes V set of
edges E and we have in the general model
multiple source destination pairs I call
them SK and TK and I say that there is
demand DK between the K source
destination pair think of that is that
many users need to route between this
particular source destination pair and
sometimes this is also called commodity
K so commodity J simply the people that
need to route from the case source to
the case destination and we consider
users being infinitesimally small so in
the jargon of this literature this is
called non-atomic players simply it
means that you can think of all players
as a flow and this flow needs to choose
feasible paths between their
corresponding source and destination
so the players decisions at the end of
the day can be encapsulated by a flow
vector and this flow vector can be
thought of as either a vector on all the
paths or a vector along the edges if
it's a vector on all the paths we have a
coordinate for each path which tells us
how many users or how much flow pick
that particular path and abuse notation
and use the same letter for a
corresponding edge flow representation
which tells me for a given edge in the
network how many users use that
particular edge and like I said we want
to capture diversity so we assume here
that users who need to select routes
here about two criteria one criterion I
will call edge delay how do you know it
denoted by the function Aliev axis with
a function on how many users choose that
edge XE and because I want to reserve
cost for the code the overall cost of a
path that a user experiences instead
call the second criteria deviation just
for the sake of using some words that we
can relate to this deviation could be
thought of as variance so it could be
thought of estatal or whatever the
second criterion happens to be and I'll
just use Sigma II have access for the
deviation so again these are two
criteria that users care about again you
can think of them as travel time and
tolls money convert it to time units or
you can think of this for example is
average travel time and something
capturing the variance and they're both
functions of the traffic on that edge XE
or the number of users on that edge so
different players trade-off these two
criteria in a different way and we
capture this via this what we call a
diversity parameter R so a player who
has diversity parameter R cheers to
minimize their first criterion plus R
times the second criterion
and the convenience of this linear
trade-off between the two is that it
ends up being nicely separable into some
over edges so for each edge the user
cares to minimize the first criterion
plus R times the second criterion and
then summing over the edges will give
them the cost they experience for a
given path
so let me since I'll be talking about
the the cost of equilibrium I want to
compare the cost of equilibria for
heterogeneous users versus homogeneous
ones there is some thought that needs to
go into how we define this cost so again
the cost of a path is straightforward
my the path the cost of some given path
is just the this linear combination of
the two criteria traded off with the
diversity parameter R but what should be
the cost of equilibrium or in general
the cost of any flaw in a traffic
assignment in the network there are two
possibilities one possibility is that
the cost of a flow should be the total
first criterion only so in the example
of tolls if people trade-off between
total travel time and money paid for
tolls the cost of a flow I'm saying here
is just a travel time so toes do not
participate in the cost of the flow and
this is consistent with the vast
literature with the vast majority of
literature on tolls this is just
standards and their different ration I
was given for that for why the money
should not participate in the cost of
slow I think the risk averse routing
application you can think of it as the
cost being only the total average travel
time not the variance because from the
point of view of a central planner who
cares about long term averages and
making the system efficient in terms of
long term averages they only care about
the total average travel time that users
experience
the second natural criterion is the
notion of social welfare from economics
which is to sum up all the users
utilities or costs and experience and
call this the cost of workflow so in
this case it would be the total over all
the users of both the first and the
second criterion or in other words the
total summation of the cost of paths
they're different users experience and I
want to point out here is that none of
them is wrong all right
they are just both applicable in
different situations depending on your
goal and there are two natural questions
that result now that we have this
different parameter are one question is
you could ask how does the equilibrium
cost and again I'll define equilibrium
cost a little later but how does the
equilibrium cost of a population with
parameter are compared to the
equilibrium cost of a population with
parameter zero so in the setting with
risk aversion for example this is
comparing how much more risk-averse
users travel compared to risk neutral
users another question is the question
of diversity here how does the
equilibrium cost of a diverse population
where diversity is captured by a
distribution of possible parameters are
how does that compare to a corresponding
homogeneous population where the
homogeneous population has an average
parameter are the average taken over the
distribution so we studied both of these
questions separately for the and we
studied them with the different costs
law definitions so for the first
question we study that for low cost
defined as the first criterion only and
this is the definition for this question
is the definition it's more sensible so
is to have a common benchmark properly
comparing populations with parameter R
to 0 and for the second question we
answer that for cost equal to total user
costs of
summing up all the path costs that
people experience and calling that the
cost of our solution yon Sigma no these
are arbitrary because if you give me the
third path I take the part on top I
function on it I won't go edge by edge
if I give you the entire path you want
to apply these functions for the entire
path now the things that you need to
apply it for every edge individually
simply because the flow amount on each
edge may be different all right
and so maybe the first part of your
route is there is nobody else on that
road it's the inside roads that take you
to the highway and nobody else is in
your neighborhood the second part is on
the highway heavy congestion traffic so
you you don't want to apply those
functions on every edge but now the
question how you how you total them
together to give you the entire path
cost may give rise to different
definitions so here I'm using linear
just adding up the costs over the edges
but you may say oh if I have something
else maybe it should be nonlinear so if
I care about standard deviation it would
be you know square root of the sum of
squares over the edges so in that sense
yeah there are multiple definitions here
I consider the linear case was it in the
before I go on let me again let me
define equilibrium formally so it's a
really the simple notion that everyone
routes a long list cost paths if there
is a path that is a smaller cost than
what I currently have I will prefer to
switch so that will not be
informally this is defined as flow X
such that whenever a path is used its
cost should be no greater than that of
any alternative now in a mathematical
way of saying that every user uses least
cost paths given the current traffic and
we call this heterogeneous equilibrium
if there are different player types with
different arts different diversity
parameters and I'll reserve the letter G
for the heterogeneous equilibrium and we
call it a homogeneous equilibrium and
again use just for notational use a
different letter F just to make them
distinct if everyone has the same
diversity parameter R
so to come back to those questions I'll
mention a few words about this first
question so I gave a longer talk on that
in the previous workshop but just to put
it in context with the other one I'll
mention a few words in you know I'll go
back to comparing diverse at equilibrium
cost with homogeneous ones so how would
we compare the equilibrium cost of a
population with parameter R to 1 with
parameter 0 so again we answer this for
the case when the flow cost is the first
criterion only and again our motivation
at a time we came from thinking about
risk-averse users and so we thought well
it makes sense again if a central
planner only cares about the total the
sum of expected travel times and again
since we were thinking about risk-averse
users we call this ratio of the two
equilibria price of risk aversion but
subsequently so this is the inefficiency
introduced by users that care for the
second criterion in addition to the to
the first one but subsequently our work
was generalized by Peter Claire and
ghido Schaffer who called this ratio the
deviation ratio less perhaps more
precise because it doesn't just apply
what to risk aversion but also tolls and
general situations when we have two
criteria surprise the risk aversion or
deviation ratio same thing essentially
is the ratio that compares the
worst-case cost of the homogenous
equilibrium when everyone has parameter
are homogeneous equilibrium when
everyone here oh and this is a typo on
everyone
his parameter zero and so again in the
same in the setting of risk aversion
this is comparing a equilibrium
resulting from risk-averse users
compared to risk neutral users in the
case of tall's
this is people who care about tall so
they don't like those versus those who
don't care about any money and just care
about travel time
what do you call it a risk aversion why
do I call it risk aversion I mean this
this name here or the choice so from
from my motivation at the beginning when
I said travel time is variable and some
people may trade off mean in invariance
the second criterion you're adding it up
over the edges you just so what your
yours I use this is it's an excellent
yeah this will make some question it
could actually result in a long
discussion so I'm I'm gonna say maybe
two words now and defer it to a longer
discussion at the end or in the break
there are many ways to model risk
aversion and you're right that in
general risk aversion is something
that's like we saw in the previous talk
that should be nonlinear as opposed to
linear if you think about expected
utility theory and here I'm saying these
things are linear so here our model
forest conversion is trading off mean
and variance so I'm calling somebody a
risk-averse user if they want to
minimize the mean plus R times variance
of their route and assuming independent
travel time distributions the variance
of route is the sum of variances over
the edges and so in that sense it is
linear now you may say oh it doesn't
make sense mean and variance are not
measured in the same units which is true
meaning standard deviation is more
meaningful but standard deviation
because of a square root is really
complicated and we've tried to analyze
that's one of the open questions we've
try to analyze this but we just haven't
been able to but also because in
practice people want to implement these
things they struggle with the same
standard deviation being nonlinear they
are heuristics where instead of taking
the correct standard deviation of a path
people just add up standard deviations
of the edges so again in that sense it's
really
it's a heuristic and so in that sense it
is it is linear here and I say that
because users incorporate both mean and
variance in their objective function I
call those risk averse as opposed to
those that have only average travel time
and I call those who is neutral that
make sense but in general your rights
risk aversion comes with maybe some
non-linearity that should be embedded in
the definition there are other there are
other concerns that when you go to a
dynamic situation real-time
decision-making has to do with things
evolving over time a time consistent
risk averse measure he has been defined
as one saw someone studied in the
context of transportation they said a
time consistent one can only be one
that's linear that's additive
otherwise it won't be time consistent
but again I'll close here there is a
huge there's a huge modeling question
with many with many possible ideas yeah
that's a great question the question is
why does risk aversion introduce
inefficiency we don't say that it does
we just say that when it does how much
more will it be so it's true that
sometimes things may get worse and
sometimes things may be may get better
and see what would be it would be and we
haven't studied it so it's another open
question any other question and so so
yeah again it doesn't have to be that
the equilibrium with parameter R is more
costly it's just that sometimes it is
and we want to understand in the worst
case how much more costly is it
and actually one taking a detour here
but one way to tackle traffic congestion
is to introduce tolls and you can think
of tolls in this case precisely there
the second criterion if you implement
the correct tools they will take you to
the socially optimal traffic assignment
and so in that case it is better so in
that sense you can maybe think it's been
studied yeah because the best is
attaining the social optimum but if you
don't introduce the right tools then you
may mess things up so much so that you
actually end up paying a much heavier
cost in the resulting traffic assignment
then without any tolls so you can think
of it maybe as a policy question as well
so again I'll just briefly say what the
result was so this deviation ratio or
price of risk aversion as we originally
called it the main result is that it
scales linearly with the size of the
network in particular we we showed that
it depends on these parameters at R K
where R is our diversity parameter it is
a parameter that captures the topology
of the network so it's something which
is one for simple parallel networks it's
also one for series parallel graphs it
becomes two for the simplest non series
paragraph the brace network and in the
worst case it can be as big as the
number of nodes over to in this case the
maximum ratio of the second criterion
over the first one at equilibrium and
this bound is tight so we have a
matching lower bound and is a very brief
intuition how this bound is shown we
show that them must exist an alternating
path this is a path of a sequence of
forward and backward edges in our
directed network and this eta is the
number of alternations how many times
you
from from where - backwards and what we
show specifically is that such an
alternating path exists for which the
forward edges carry higher risk neutral
flow whereas the backward ones carry
higher risk averse flow and in that way
we are able to compare the risk averse
equilibrium cost to the cost of this
path I mean the cost of this path to the
risk neutral one and obtain the bound
and some people when when they who are
used to seeing a price of Anarchy
something I haven't defined here but
I'll just state it for those who who are
aware price of energy we think of as
typically constant so there is a famous
price of Anarchy result price of energy
for general networks is four over three
in general networks if we have linear
delay functions but again that constant
is heavily dependent on one assumption
on what your latency functions can be
whereas this is a different type of
bound which is independent so this works
for general latency and deviation
functions whereas if we take the
alternative approach of bounding the
class of latency functions which we get
something comparable to those price of
Anarchy results we get the price of risk
aversion or deviation ratio as you wish
is at most the corresponding price of
energy times a slightly inflated factor
to account for the additional diversity
and the trade-off of the second - the
first criterion anyway that's all I'll
say about this and I want to come back
to the question of diversity so how does
the equilibrium cost of a heterogeneous
population compared to one of a
corresponding homogeneous population and
let me come back again to the costs of
those equilibria we compare the
heterogeneous equilibrium to a
corresponding homogeneous one where the
diversity parameter is the average
tribution that we observe in the
heterogeneous case specifically the
average is simply for a single commodity
is simply the weighted average this is
remember how many users are this is how
many users are of type I who have
diversity parameter are I this is the
weighted average so the average
parameter is the weighted average of
those diversity parameters and the
equivalent definition follows for a
continuous distribution of diverse
population and here D is my total demand
for all players of a given type so again
for a single commodity my heterogeneous
equilibrium is adding up all the player
costs all the user costs so remember it
a user with diversity parameter R I so I
here is a subscript should be a
subscript experience is that cost of the
pass stage shows and so those that many
users experience that cost and adding up
of all the users gives me the total
heterogeneous cost and again to further
highlight the difference between
heterogeneous and homogeneous I also add
the superscripts heterogeneous and
homogeneous just to remind me what I'm
talking about
for a homogenous equilibrium everyone
has the same average diversity parameter
R and therefore everyone will experience
the same path cost because routing from
the same source or same destination if
you have a choice of multiple paths if
two are not equal you'll switch to the
cheaper one so in equilibrium all the
paths that are used have the same cost
given by some cost here and we multiply
by the total demand in for multi
commodity you I didn't want to put it
here to not have the extra notation you
just take the sum over the multiple
commodities
and so to again I gave you a preview of
our results at the beginning which we're
talking about different network
structures so let me explain briefly
what these different network structures
are so for the single commodity case the
result was that diversity helps if and
only if the graph is series-parallel so
what's the series parallel graph
something that looks like that and not
something that looks like that so the
multiple definitions one that is
commonly given is an inductive
definition which says that the simplest
series-parallel network is a single edge
and we can obtain all possible series
parallel networks either by replacing an
edge by two edges in parallel or by two
edges in series so if continue we
continue this process on and on we are
going to reach a whole family of series
parallel networks of which this one is
one such example and something that
results from this definition is that we
can represent series parallel networks
in terms of their block representation
so what do I mean by that series
parallel networks might be a single
block such as this one or multiple
blocks by a block I mean so since I
connect sometimes things in in series a
series parallel network we look like
this where individual blocks cannot be
represented as a two networks in series
that's all yeah so so I'm talking about
your correct
so series parallel in general can be
defined for undirected and directed for
my talk I'm using directed but here I've
just drawn happen to draw undirected
situations but you imagine all those
links direct its pointing forward
and so here just because I was lazy just
want to make multiple copies to make a
block representation of a series Network
parallel network with three blocks this
one is a theorist parallel network with
one block but you can imagine a series
parallel network with multiple blocks
and so I'll be calling them this is the
s the beginning v1 v2 and so on will be
my intermediary nose think of those as
the bridges that you have to go through
single points all the way to the
destination so this is the block
representation of a series parallel
network and for the multi commodity
results the characterization is in terms
of what I call block matching networks
so those are networks which so a series
parallel network only is meaningful for
a single origin and destination if we
have multiple origins and destinations
think of interweaving multiple series
parallel networks between those
corresponding sources and destinations
and here is an example where I have two
source destination pairs s 1 T 1 and s 2
T 2 all the simple paths from s 1 to T 1
are captured by a series parallel
network given in red here and it's red
network has four blocks ABC and D all
simple path from s 2 to t 2 captured via
6 blocks or or 5 however many let's see
II D F which is a single edge b c and j
and so we called such an inter weaving
of series parallel graphs block matching
whenever two blocks from two different
commodities either entirely coincide or
they do not share any edges
Sarala roots are always planar or no let
me think quickly series-parallel
are they always planar there's someone
in the audience have a quick answer to
that yes okay I'll take that as a dancer
I blanked out okay yes and so you you
see here that those two commodities the
green one in the red one share two
blocks in common block B and block D so
Block B in block D are entirely the same
and all the other blocks are entirely
disjoint meaning they can they might
share the same node but they have no
edges in common so
here is which way did I so like I said
the result is that for a single
commodity when everyone has the same
source and destination diversity always
helps if and only if the network is
series-parallel so we prove that in two
stages its if and only if so we go in
one direction and the other so starting
with if we have a series parallel
network then diversity always helps
regardless of the choice of delay and
deviation functions how do we prove
something like that the key lemma is
that there exists paths in the network
which is used by the homogeneous flow
which has lower heterogeneous cost and
this is not always true so this is only
true for series parallel networks in the
way to prove this lemma is by induction
on the series parallel structure of the
graph and once we have this lemma the
main result follows just following the
definition of equilibrium costs so I
said the equilibrium cost for the
heterogeneous equilibrium is the total
sum over all the costs of heterogeneous
agents they are using lowest cost paths
and so they are upper bounded by some
this fixed path P and then I use the
lemma to transition from the
heterogeneous flow to the homogeneous
flow and finally I get the homogeneous
equilibrium cost
in the opposite direction if we do not
have a series parallel Network the
simplest such network is a network of
this form sometimes called the brace
graph we come up with specific delay and
deviations functions for which diversity
hurts so we have higher cost of the
heterogeneous equilibrium and to show
that for any no series parallel graph
again diversity may hurt is we embed
this network in the general non series
parallel networking sometimes one
definition or one characterization of
series parallel graphs are graphs that
do not do not contain this sub graph as
a minor and so again we embed this and
we get the result for for general no
series parallel networks so that's the
if and only for for single source and
destination for multiple source and
destination again if we start with the
block matching network this direction is
easy from the single commodity because
we showed it a single commodity when we
restrict the network to that single
commodity it's a series parallel network
therefore diversity helps and summing up
over all the commodities we get the
diversity helps always for such block
matching networks and the real tough
part is to show it in the opposite way
to show the block matching networks are
actually necessary for diversity to
hurts and we do that again by
constructing a small example on which
diversity hurts in this case it's a two
commodity example with only three paths
the first one going from s 1 to T 1 the
second going from X 2 to t 2 there is a
single path from s to T 2
while there are two possible routes from
s 1 to t 1 and here there are only two
edges for which we assign non negative
delay and deviation functions all the
others have zero so it's those two edges
that determine how the flow will go and
what happens is that we can assign such
functions such that in the homogeneous
case all the users
we'll use the top so the bottom will not
be congested in the overall did I say
that wrong I'll not confuse myself and
you at this point but basically you can
come up with delay and deviation
functions for those two edges such that
diversity won't hurt the homogeneous
flow will be lower and now how to do
that in how to prove the general theorem
I'll just mention I'll spend maybe two
minutes on the flow of logic of the
proof and a little insight and I'll
conclude so first of all buy the single
commodity necessity Theory theorem we
know that the sub Network for each
commodity must be series parallel so we
apply the single commodity theorem if
diversity always helps we must have a
series parallel network for a single
commodity so for every commodity we have
a series parallel network but those may
overlap in many different ways and to
show that they overlap in exactly the
block matching way that I described we
need to show that if we if I take any
two commodities and I need two blocks in
those commodities either those two
blocks entirely coincide or they have no
common edges in this part now to prove
that I use the proof by contradiction so
suppose not suppose I find two
commodities and two blocks so that they
share an edge but I do not entirely
coincide so one has an edge that the
other one doesn't have
I'll get a crunk contradiction by a
careful construction embedding the
previous example that I showed and
that's that looks quite messy on the
figure and the proof itself is quite
messy so just to try to convey a very
brief flavor we show that if a path for
the second commodity must use an edge
from this first commodity being this
edge cannot be an internal edge it must
be that if they share any common edges
that green path must enter Block B from
its beginning and exited from the end
and if all mean that the entire block B
must be used by the second commodity
also therefore contradicting that B has
one more edge that is and to show that
the contradiction that this common edge
cannot be internal it must be from the
beginning if it is internal we basically
are able to construct careful with
carefully chosen delay and deviation
functions a way to guide the flow so
that the flow goes exactly in the way
that it went in this simple case and I
think not going to any more details now
not to confuse you but but basically
with a very careful construction we we
show an example where if there is
internal diversity Hertz
therefore obtaining that is at
contradiction it's all just there is a
lot of related work you know refer it to
the papers but I'll just conclude again
stating the main results that diversity
helps if and only if the network is
series parallel for a single commodity
and correspondingly if and only if it is
block matched for multiple commodities
[Applause]
so is the Bay Area road network lock
master it's the Bay Area is the very
road network look bad say I haven't
stared at it enough probably not in one
of your earlier talks you cited an
example where drivers might be risk
seeking for example if the mean travel
time won't get you to your flight on
time but if you get lucky on a on a road
with high variance you might do so so
does it make sense to increase your
diversity in this model by including
risk seeking as well as risk-averse
drivers so when I said that it was more
of a play on the words it was I said it
when users are risk averse they actually
may prefer a gamble if this is the only
thing that gets them positive
probability of arriving on time it was
actually in these guys the risk-averse
model again but you sure you may come up
maybe with an example where users select
risk seeking routes instead and then I
guess I haven't thought about it here a
hard time letting it melt all these
results
what is the source of the answer so yeah
this goes to things that are a little
bit outside this model so here I will
this talk really was not about
uncertainty at all it was just about
trading off two criteria but if you took
the motivation for risk aversion is
providing two criteria such as mean and
variance
really both exhaustion assigning
endogenous you is that what you had in
mind so traffic accidents weather
anything that that might cause thank you
very much
[Applause]